y llegó el momento de hacer un repaso
por lo que dicen otros medios
internacionales revista de prensa nos
acompaña como todos los días de la
semana Marta Moya Marta bienvenida Hola
María Clara Buenos días buen comienzo de
semana para usted y lo hacemos con una
noticia que es una exclusiva del
Washington post y que está moviendo toda
la atención en torno a la guerra en
Ucrania y es que ellos están afirmando
que el líder de la milicia
wagnerygoshi que a pesar de que ha
respaldado a Rusia supuestamente habría
tenido contacto con la inteligencia
ucraniana para vender la información
sobre dónde estaban las tropas de Moscú
sí María Clara esta exclusiva del
Washington analiza estos documentos
secretos que se filtraron hace unos
meses y que no habían llegado Esto sí
estos documentos a la opinión pública
sino que son una exclusiva del
Washington post los documentos llamados
como discords
que el líder del grupo
wagnershin habría estado en contacto con
agentes de la cúpula de inteligencia
militar ucraniana para que los soldados
de kiev se retiraran de bahamut y para
que él pudiera obtener esta Victoria en
esta urbe que llevan disputa unos diez
meses las conversaciones se habrían dado
tanto por teléfono Como en un país no
especificado del continente africano
esto dice la exclusiva del Washington
post a cambio pregojin ofrecía a la
cúpula militar ucraniana dar las
coordenadas de las posiciones de las
tropas rusas en otras localizaciones
para que los ucranianos pudieran
redireccionar esas ofensivas los
documentos no aclaran eso sí qué
posiciones estaría dispuesto a ofrecer
pri gojing si dicen que esta oferta se
hizo en más de una ocasión pero que no
se llevó a término por la desconfianza
de los ucranianos hacia prigong y
aconsejó que los ucranianos se centraran
en atacar la frontera de aprovechando la
baja moral de las tropas rusas también
revelan estos documentos una pugna por
el poder
y las altas cúpulas militares del
Ministerio de defensa comandado por el
ministro sergey a pesar de que usted nos
habla de la desconfianza de las fuerzas
ucranianas esta exclusiva también señala
que el presidente ucraniano y tenía la
intención y la voluntad de atacar más
puntos rusos pues semara Clara y además
una cosa curiosa es que el pentágono no
niega pues la veracidad de estos
documentos esta segunda exclusiva del
Washington post dice textualmente las
intercepciones estadounidenses revelan
los instintos agresivos del líder
ucraniano un marcado contraste con su
imagen pública como el estadista estoico
que resistió que resistió el brutal
ataque de Rusia los llamados de
occidente han sido recurrentes para que
Ucrania No utilice la munición dada por
occidente para destacar puntos de el
país de Rusia no Y además a Puerta
cerrada
bolodimir zelemski habría dicho que no
siempre ha mantenido estas intenciones
de no atacar Rusia según estos
documentos filtrados por el Washington
post y unos documentos clasificados como
top Secret helensky sugirió en una
reunión a finales de enero trasladar
tropas terrestres de Ucrania a puntos
territorios fronterizos con Rusia y
ocupar ciudades no especificadas de
fronterizas con Rusia en otra reunión
con el principal líder militar ucraniano
dijo que Ucrania tenía que atacar con
drones la región de rostov en el oeste
ruso ya que no le estaban suministrando
misiles de largo alcance algo que ya ha
cambiado con el anuncio de Reino Unido
de la semana pasada y en otro encuentro
con la viceprimera ministra ucraniana A
mediados de febrero sostienen estos
documentos del Washington bosque
sugerido explotar un oleoducto que
conecta Rusia con Hungría una respuesta
airada contra el Primer Ministro húngaro
Víctor orbán por sus vínculos con
Vladimir Putin y por su negativa a pues
secundar las sanciones de la Unión
Europea y recordemos que hace pocas
semanas Rusia dijo que Ucrania había
provocado el descarrilamiento de un tren
en la ciudad rusa de brians lo que
estaría acorde con lo que usted nos está
diciendo Pero bueno públicamente que si
dice el presidente
pues María Clara esto también es una
entrevista concedida al Washington post
por parte del presidente ucraniano el 1
de Mayo ha corresponsales y Editores del
Washington post en el este de Europa es
una tensa entrevista alrededor de todas
estas filtraciones y publicaciones del
washingtonsky dice que las afirmaciones
de la inteligencia estadounidense son
fantasías pero sí defendió su derecho a
utilizar tácticas no convencionales para
defender
Ucrania zelensky en esta entrevista El
Washington post no quiso dar legitimidad
a los documentos filtrados en discord y
además dijo que no quería creer que
Estados Unidos hubiese estado espiando a
Ucrania durante meses y que esto no
mermaba la confianza en su principal
socio que es Washington además dijo que
las reuniones entre primos y los líderes
de la inteligencia forman parte de una
cuestión meramente de la inteligencia
pero no las negó y además dice que
proporcionarán los datos totales de Las
bajas ucranianas cuando acabe la guerra
y que la inversión de la lucha por
bajmud no ha sido en vano porque de
hacerlo y haberse retirado de basmut
hubiese insuflado mucha moral a las
tropas del kremlin que hubieran vendido
la victoria de basmut como Pues un
avance Claro en su ofensiva mucha
información entonces Marta por debajo de
la cuerda como suele pasar en todas las
guerras donde la información también se
convierte en uno de los objetos y a
propósito de confusiones a intrigas Qué
está pasando con la salud del presidente
bielorruso Alexander lucaschenko sí
María Clara hemos destacado un artículo
del Guardian pero ya está en
prácticamente todos los medios
internacionales los crecientes rumores
sobre el estado de salud del presidente
bielorruso y todo esto nace de una
publicación de un medio de comunicación
bielorruso asociado a la oposición que
dijo que este fin de semana lucashenko
habría sido trasladado a una clínica
privada en Minsk en la capital
Bielorrusia de bielorrusa perdón a
lucasenco no se le ve en público desde
el 9 de mayo el día de la Victoria donde
participó en los eventos conmemorativos
en Moscú sin embargo estuvo ausente en
un importante acto en la capital
Bielorrusia ayer domingo donde jóvenes
juran lealtad ante la bandera del estado
y además Fuentes asociadas al gobierno
no hicieron ninguna declaración sobre la
ausencia del presidente aunque fuera muy
extraña solo se refirió el presidente a
través de un comunicado escrito que leyó
un Bueno un participante del gobierno en
este acto conmemorativo además estuvo
presente en Moscú pero no estuvo
presente en Bielorrusia haciendo un
discurso por el día de la Victoria algo
que nunca jamás ha hecho en sus más de
20 años de presidencia por tanto todos
estos rumores sumados dan lugar a
especulaciones sobre si el estado de
salud de lukashenko está en óptimas
condiciones o si está pasando algo que
evidencia esa ausencia en los últimos
actos recientes
en Bielorrusia y en Rusia alguna razón
del peso tendrá para faltar por primera
vez en 20 años a esta clase de eventos
Marta terminemos rápidamente vais una
multimillonaria cadena mediática se
declara en bancarrota sí María Clara lo
ha anunciado este lunes todo ello para
acelerar su venta esta empresa vices
news que engloba por Baez media Group
opera desde 1994 sin embargo ahora ya ha
decidido dar paso a unos prestamistas
para que la adquieran hace unas semanas
ya anunció la cancelación de su programa
televisivos Tonight un programa
ampliamente seguido por la audiencia
estadounidense y esto ya se enmarcaba en
una oleada de despidos en el interno de
la empresa esta noticia se viene a sumar
a otra tendencia de recorte de personal
y cierre de medios en Estados Unidos con
recortes de las plantillas de la mpr del
Washington post o incluso el cierre
anunciado también hace unas semanas de
bashfred news bueno malas noticias para
las cadenas mediáticas Gracias Marta por
toda esta revista de prensa gracias Me
declaro